[Music]
here's the thing
when a pandemic hits
when six dollar gas hits
when
a loaf of bread goes up
when there's 73 people trying to buy one
house
and they run the price up
when it's weird out there when you walk
through the grocery store and there's
not crap on the shelves
okay
you have a different
physical
reaction
to those things
you have a different
emotional and spiritual reaction to
these things
a lot less drama
to these things
when you are the third pig
you remember the third pig
he's the one that had a brick house
and when the big bad wolf came
his pulse rate did not change
he looked out the window and said oh
there's a wolf
when the big bad wolf came to the other
houses he huffed and he puffed and he
blew their freaking house down and their
lives were coming to an end
right
so when you have
an emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses
when you are living on a budget
when you have worked your butt off and
gotten yourself out of debt
and all this crap comes at you
your pulse rate doesn't change
you go that gum that's awful it's
inconvenient
they don't have cream cheese at publix
you know
it's just a thing right can i be a
fourth pig
the fourth pig can i be the fourth pig i
don't know
the fourth pig is you do it all right
thank god for parents that teach you
young you do it you're living on a
budget since 21 you save up your
emergency
your funding your 401k
you're doing it okay so you got the
brick house
but the dad go move but he's real and
when you when that pig goes to the
grocery store it's like
dang it publix it's so it is though so
you so the fourth pig was a drama
student maybe so the fourth pick can
have the brick house but the fourth pick
also feels it
when you fill up your tank and you're
like no
why is it so expensive or costco i check
out and it's it feels like it's
almost like i didn't say you didn't feel
it but it doesn't have to have the level
of drama that you're bringing to it i
know but it god sucks
i didn't say it didn't suck and let me
just tell you let me tell you when it
sucks more when you're not the third pig
i've been there i mean it's like when
you're broke everything that can go
wrong well and then they throw some of
this crap on top of it totally
absolutely your life looks like a
country
biden wrote i mean it's awful you know
what i mean it's horrible it it it
creates it creates a huge it but the
level of stress that you have the level
of anxiety that you have around
inflationary matters changes
dramatically or should totally if you
have your crap together because you've
been following this stuff this is the
stuff that we the stuff that we teach is
the only
principles in finance that work in
prosperous times and in hard times yes
but also so i would say the fourth pig
lives too like when coveted hit right
everything every i know on the fourth
pick i don't know making it up as we go
i know i can tell but it's the same
feeling as with covet that the people
that were debt free had an emergency
fund all of that their level of fear was
way less yeah they went all that but
there was still a level of god like you
know i hadn't thought of the level yeah
i may not get it done that's what i was
trying to acknowledge that even though
financially the dollars and cents you
can still pay for the gas and like
adjust your budget and you're fine you
can pay for it yeah the dupes cut the
stupid pump off at 125 dollars i can't
even fill up the truck
you know
i got to do it twice to fill it up
that's why you need to go green i know
but plug up oh good you don't have to do
it oh good lord
oh this is going downhill fast but um
so i can't fill up my truck the point is
though
that
when you
are prepared and you have done the
things that we teach
this stuff does not have as much of an
effect on you unless you choose drama
but the drama and the anxiety when
you're broke
is
very real yes i remember i remember that
yeah
it's uh you know like the lonely says
your body remembers it you know and and
so yeah i
uh
when the difference in uh four dollar
gas and six dollar gas
is
is a huge percentage of your world
because you haven't done these things
yet
or you've never chosen to do these
things these things being getting out of
debt saving money living on a budget
living on less than you make so that you
can build wealth so that you've got some
buffer between you and all this crap
that's out there
that's the third pick
and it is a real thing that um
you know
it doesn't mean you're you're looking
down on the little people it doesn't
mean that at all it just means that
you're the third pig and the the wolf is
out there and he's huffing and puffing
but you're not going to die you know and
so the anxiety if you're if you have
reasonable mental health should be lower
you should not be at the same drama
level
and and so that's a real thing and and
so and that's the one of the benefits
and yeah and it's why you do this yeah
that's right that's right that's why you
do this because guess what if your
anxiety level due to inflationary issues
or whatever it is budgetary problems is
lower it affects your relationship when
you go home at night with your kids and
your spouse you know it affects how you
do your job at work because you're not
sitting and wringing your hands and you
know you can actually concentrate get
your job done guess what and then you
get promotions and so this whole thing
leads to prosperity and and away from
the other
and so this should be yet one more time
in your life if you're out there and
have never decided i'm going to get out
of debt you've never really decided i'm
going to get on a budget i've never
really decided i'm going to build some
wealth and have an emergency fund
this is one more reminder to be the
third pig
because you do have less stress yes you
should have
less stress absolutely
it doesn't mean it's not there it
doesn't mean you don't know it's there
and i was even though doesn't mean
you're in denial that people are having
a hard time somewhere else other than
you you're not a snob that's not what
i'm talking about i'm just saying the
natural reaction should be
it's inconvenient versus
it's world ending yes yes
and even the simple thing i was talking
to someone who's getting out of debt
just being on a budget she was saying
she was like even just that gives me a
sense of control and peace because i
know where to adjust and all of it and
even though it's still tight and it's
like oh it's frustrating it still gives
you this level of control versus like
you're saying just laying out and being
like oh my gosh everything's just
happening to me and i don't know what to
do
giving yourself the ability to control
what you can control and that's this
plan of getting an emergency fund in
place living on a budget working your
way out of debt so you don't owe anyone
anything building up an emergency fund
a fully funded one yeah all of this
right is to get to that point so i
totally concur i just want to say they
were still out of cream cheese so that's
the only thing i was saying in the break
is that
there are still a few things that are
bare on the shelves and
i i'm just saying it's not the end of
the world
and and and it's less the end of the
world it's less drama and less stress
when you're the third pig
or
unless you've graduated to the fourth
pick which is the third pig with drama
apparently but whatever that is i don't
know exactly what that is right now
we're gonna rewrite the fable at this
point but um we have to have a ramsey
version of the fable
and rachel's gonna tell us how to do the
first company
this is horrible
i don't know
if only you you just
you're just scared of death i'm not
going to be empathetic of the people out
there well you know all you said is that
it didn't hurt month-to-month the
grocery bill and i thought i hurt my
every dollar it hurt when i had to track
that dang costco transaction i thought
dad gummit
i'm it's just more it just eats into it
my little line on my over dollar budget
went way further than it did last month
and that means that less pizza for you
and that's a problem
we get the fourth pig when we have less
pizza that's where the fourth pig comes
out